what if Zoro killed every single pirate
he came across to buy himself a place
amongst the celestial dragons what if
Frankie ego istically used the
blueprints passed down to him by Tom to
turn himself into the ancient weapon
pluton or what if Luffy had been the one
who had actually stabbed Ace in the back
in order to become a warlord in other
words what would it look like if the
straw head Pirates were truly evil now
believe it or not jimbe was first
introduced all the way back in chapter
69 nice and that was actually by zoro's
bouncy Hunter friends here when they
talked about the seven Warlords and
according to their highly inaccurate
Silhouettes right here these monstrous
Pirates were feared throughout the grand
line and then just a few chapters later
Dracula mihawk confirmed their exact
power when he cut a massive ship in half
and then nearly cut Zoro in half as well
now of course when we're finally
actually introduced to jimbe we do find
out that he's actually just a big cuddly
Teddy shark guy but what would it have
taken for this fearsome fishermen to
have actually turned to the dark s side
well surprisingly not much actually
because in fact arlong shared a
backstory with jimbe and just look how
he turned out as a quick reminder after
the common Mentor Fisher Tiger's death
arlong cursed humans and sought violent
revenge for all of the Discrimination
that the fishermen had faced jimbe on
the other hand decided to walk a
difficult but Noble Path in honoring
Fisher Tiger's Legacy and deciding to
become a walll for the greater good of
fishermen Island's future however let's
be real here jimbe could have taken the
easy way out just like arlong very much
as well and so he wouldn't just want
peace for Fishman Island he would make
Fishman Island a world power in his
Conquest for revenge against humanity as
a result jimbe and arlong could have
sailed together as fearsome co- captains
of the new Sun Pirates shining a light
on the misdeeds of H humans throughout
the grand line and generally terrorizing
the globe together using his incredibly
powerful fisherman karate jimbe would
cut down ships leaving Marine soldiers
and civilians alike to drown in the
Dreadful Waters of the world's most
dangerous ocean unfortunately though
this would very likely have caused the
world government to pass Divine judgment
on Fishman Island and after a very hard
for battle against the Admirals arlong
and jimbe both would have ended up in
imple down only that this time around
when Luffy finally finds jimbe in level
six of imple he would actually deserve
to be locked up in there cuz if the
humans of the one piece world would
treat him like a monster then he would
act like one and interestingly enough
the same goes for another monstrous
member of the straw hat crew chopper as
a regular reindeer who ended up eating
the human human fruit Chopper was shunt
by the rest of the reindeer in his herd
for being different from everyone else
and tragically enough even though he had
developed human intelligence the
villagers of drum Island also feared him
as a a beast now in the end as you know
he finally found Hope in the form of his
mentor Dr Holo who in the end helped him
find his dream of becoming a powerful
doctor however once Dr hiroo died
eventually Chopper was devastated not
only that he basically felt largely
responsible for his mentor's death
having given him a poisonous mushroom
thinking that it would heal his disease
and so it's not so hard to imagine that
Dr Korea might have refus Dr herol
look's request to take in Chopper and
teach him medicine or even worse if w 's
Army had successfully found and executed
her like he did with the other doctors
on the islands who wouldn't join his
private medical team and then thinking
back about the drum island arc it
literally might be the only country out
there that has even more restricted
Health Care than the United States but
we're getting off topic here because in
this dark timeline Chopper would be left
to fend for himself in the cold winter
Wilderness of drum Island while sitting
around the fire in an icy night
residents of the Island's Villages would
spread rumors of a Beast wandering the
Snows at night they'd warn each other
and their children against going out
after dark for the monster would come
into the villages to scavenge for food
and supplies now what would these
supplies be for well just because Dr
Holo died it doesn't mean that Chopper
would lose his intelligence or curiosity
in other words he would still be very
much experimenting with chemistry but
this time wouldn't just become
knowledgeable in medicine he would learn
how to manipulate poisons and other
dangerous substances as well he would
also not follow the same code of ethics
when practicing medicine and would be
fully willing to experiment on living
subjects in order to develop medicines
as well and so when this version of
Chopper would see people like Caesar
Clown experimenting on innocent children
on Punk Hazard he would simply say let's
go brother I want to join in he would
also still use science to experiment on
his own devil fruit transformation using
the rumble balls which would allow choer
to become a true monster Beast by
accessing monster point on a regular
basis using using that power he would
reduce wap's Castle to rubble and become
the de facto ruler of the islands in
fact Oda hints that this is what would
happen to Chopper in a darker timeline
in case you're not aware in the SPs
section of the manga volumes he has
drawn alternate future versions for most
of the straw hats and choppers shows him
as a grotesque Beast demanding
sacrifices and so when Luffy and his
evil crew finally showed up they'd think
a beast like evil Chopper would fit
right into their crew of monsters as
well and Choppa would take the
opportunity to find more knowledge
poisons and sacrifices all across the
grand line and also joining the evil
Straw Hat crew on a quest for knowledge
and world domination would be the devil
child Nico Robin after defeating the
wards or crocodile and claiming the
kingdom of alabaster as his own
territory Luffy would recruit Robin to
his side as well after all miss all
Sunday had proven herself to be quite
capable and cunning as a fighter and
assassin had saved Luffy's life in the
hopes that he would defeat her employer
and came with the added bonus of knowing
how to rate the poneglyphs which as it
turns out are set to reveal the secrets
of the ancient weapons knowledge that
could turn the world upside down and
that evil Luffy very much would like to
get his hands on now na Robin has spent
her entire life on the run from the
government always sticking to the side
of the strong in order to somehow
protect herself and so when a rising
star showed the potential to become the
next pirate king it would be natural for
this lifelong criminal to join his crew
only that in our dark timeline here we
would sadly never see the Kinder gentler
true version of Robin that opened up to
the straw hats in the end instead she
would just silently follow along with
the crew in order to meet her own goal
of uncovering the secrets of the
poneglyphs but once she accomplished her
dream of uncovering the true history
what would she then do well an evil
Robin would definitely take these
secrets about the ancient weapons and
use them to destroy the world
governments and even the world if they
thought that the Buster call on Ohara
was justified just wait and see what
destruction Robin could cause with the
ancient weapons freely at her disposal
now to be fair if the straw hats were
evil when cp9 steals Robin away the crew
probably wouldn't save her because she's
their treasured friend they would do it
because she's the key to reaching the
end of the grand line sought after by
every major pirate crew and the Marines
alike she is a tool for Luffy and while
it's truly heartbreaking to think that
this version of Robin would just spend
the rest of her life quietly suffering
away the very bright side for us is that
in this timeline she would very likely
keep the cool cowboy hat and the bangs
for way longer than she did in the
actual story now our next character on
the other hand wouldn't be quietly
suffering he'd actually be very loudly
suffering he turned his suffering up to
11 because making noise is his whole
deal you see Brook's entire crew that he
love died horrible deaths while their
ship was trapped inside the floran
triangle and only thanks to his devil
fruit he then found himself inhabiting
his own decayed skeleton body he was no
longer Flesh and Blood he was a shadow
of his former self and then even that
was stolen from him by geko Moria and so
to be honest that should be enough to
drive anyone absolutely insane and so
when the evil straw hats TM would find
themselves in the shrouded mids of the
Florian triangle they'd encounter this
skele and immediately demand that he
would join their crew and just like good
Luffy immediately took a liking to broke
evil Luffy also would immediately want a
cool Skeleton on his crew and his face
perfectly matches their Jolly Roger now
as you probably know Brook stream
originally is to eventually reunite with
laboon but having gone completely insane
in out of dark timeline evil Brook will
only want to do so because he's pulled a
complete Captain ahop except instead of
losing his leg he lost all of his flesh
and skin skin and in his mind Twisted by
loneliness he would think that laboon
had abandoned him his last friend alive
leaving him to suffer in the Florian
triangle and so with his new signature
weapon the garoon in his hand he would
take out laboon and then sell his meat
for huge profits and in this timeline
Bing sake wouldn't just be a song for
fun parties for the straw head's enemies
it would be the last thing that they
ever hear but as it turns out Brooke
isn't the only evil straw hat that would
cease to be alive completely either
because in Frankie's dark timeline as
drawn by Oda as well he goes beyond
being just a cyborg who's augmented his
body into making himself fully a machine
just like Dr Vega Punk did to Kuma
Frankie would use his mechanical knowhow
to turn himself into the Ultimate Weapon
the battle Frankie 50 and in uda's dark
official timeline drawing he looks like
his main body has just become the
general Frankie and he says the
forboding line that he must eliminate
All Ships now this of course would make
him the perfect addition to the evil
straw head crew as Dave traveled across
the grand line he would sink the ships
of any rival warlord Supernova and
Emperor alike in his mission to destroy
All Ships now when the straw hats
originally met Frankie he was a Crim
Lord in water 7 leading his own gang but
this time around instead of having a
really nice and heartwarming Redemptive
arc when he meets the STW hats when he
meets the # evil straw hats he would
just fit right in the way he was but
eventually he do something even better
than just building the straw hat to
Thousand Sunny because Oda gives us
another version of Frankie 20 more years
down the line where he's actually turned
himself into not just a cyborg but into
the ultimate Battleship the battle
Franky 70 in other words he wouldn't
just build a ship worthy of the evil
pirate king he would would be the ship
and honestly this evil version of
Frankie would have had no reservations
at all against actually utilizing the
pluton blueprints that had been passed
down to him from Iceberg and so as a
result as a battleship Frankie would
have the destructive power of a literal
ancient weapon build into him and since
the evil straw head crew would then
essentially be using pluton as their
ship which by the way they might
actually be doing in the actual story as
well who knows they would be able to lay
waste to basically anyone in their path
as they sail down to find the one piece
and of course to steer this ancient
weapon Battleship Frankie through the
Grand line the crew will need a truly
evil Navigator as well because as it
happens cat burglar Nami is already
quite motivated by greed and crime she
craves riches and treasure like the good
pirate she is and since she had years in
years of experience on the crew of the
infamous arlong she'll still fit right
into the evil Straw Hat crew as well
once Luffy gave arlong a beating Nami
would know that if she really wanted to
make cash for her own gains not to buy
back kokosi Village then betting on
Luffy would be the right move after all
with monsters like Luffy Zoro and Sanji
on the crew all she'd have to do is lay
back and steer the ship while the
treasures just came flowing in and in
this version of the straw hats evil Nami
would be very much true to her name even
though she's called the cat burglar in a
wanted post she rarely actually uses her
skills of stealth and infiltration in
fact other straw heads like Robin or
Brooke or Sanji even have taken the
stealth missions instead but this
version of Nami wouldn't just be in
charge of getting the straw hats to the
next destination she would be robbing
those destinations blind and then going
on shopping spree across the island to
fill every spare room of Battleship
Frankie with lavish luxuries now you
might ask what about nami's love of
navigation and mapmaking well she did
learn something from her evil mental
arlong and that's that it's a whole lot
easier to just have someone else do the
work for you and so she could just use
the riches that she stole to Simply pay
someone to make maps for her or better
yet she can just chain people up and
force them to do the work and so
meanwhile she can just sit back and
relax while eating the decadent dishes
prepared by her personal chef Sanji and
let me tell you that oda's drawing for a
evil version of Sanji are TR
fascinating in the very first one he
stops caring about how Gourmet his
dishes are instead he just thinks that
all food is the same as long as it fills
your belly and even though this is
admittedly a huge shift from his current
mindset we feel that he'd still pull out
all the culinary stops for at least Nami
because let's be real his love for every
beautiful woman isn't just going to go
away even in the darkest of alternate
universes in fact probably just the
opposite and once he finally found the
all blue Sanji wouldn't use it to create
the ultimate seafood dishes instead he'd
start a commercial fishery destroying
the all bl's ecosystem and using the
funds to support his evil empire because
evil Sanji has a whole Kingdom to
inherit and manage because Oda also Drew
an even older version of Sanji that has
even more terrifying implication in a
timeline where everything and I mean
everything goes wrong Sanji doesn't deny
his Vince name he Embraces it this
picture has Sanji looking exactly like
his father Vince smog jut he's grown out
his mustache which will now be perfect
for twirling villainously you know and
as a member of the evil straw hats he'd
overtake his family for control of the
German Kingdom and so really the only
thing scarier than seeing the ancient
weapon Battleship Frankie thundering
towards you would be the ancient weapon
Battleship Frankie followed by hundreds
or thousands of giant germa snails f
filled to the brim with soldiers and of
course leading that massive Fleet
including at least 8,000 men under the
straw head Banner would be Captain
sniper god king Usopp the master
manipulator Uso's greatest strength
other than his Wicked aim of course has
always been his ability as a liar in the
main story he uses this ability in a
kind of heartwarming way like cheering
up Kaa with his stories or something
like that but in this dark evil timeline
usub would use ability to bend others to
his will and trick them into doing his
bidding you know think a long-nosed
version of Johan from Monster who could
get innocent people to commit murder
with just a short conversation and with
each of these giant germa snails
containing also a battalion of giants
from elb the evil straw head Grand Fleet
will sure be to strike fear into every
island across the five Seas of one piece
and as for Usopp master of lies and
deception children everywhere will fear
Him parents will tell their kids that
they had better behave because the
devilish sniper god king can hit a
naughty person from anywhere in the
world and so the only true words out of
evil Uso's mouth from this point onwards
will be Tales of Conquest pillaging and
murder but of course that blood lust
pales in comparison to the next straw
hats ronoa Zoro because Zoro is already
a quite Savage and ruthless swordsman
with a secret part of gold in the actual
story but now take away that Heart of
Gold well you get a real demon for the
fighter and honorary first mate of the
evil straw hats because for someone
whose epithets ranged from Pirate Hunter
and just straight up to King of hell he
might just be long on the evil Straw Hat
crew TM more than the other regular
straw hats as you know Zoro never got
his chance to defeat his rival Kina and
instead fate took his opportunity to
become the strongest away when kinaa
died in another timeline though instead
of taking her death With Honor and
trying to achieve their shared dream for
her sake as well Zoro would be consumed
by rage he would still try to become the
strongest swordsman but instead of
honoring the tenants Of the Bushido Cod
he would mercilessly cut down anyone in
his path on his Conquest to become the
truly strongest and of course that would
be perfect for his role as the
right-hand man of the evil Straw Hat
Captain Luffy and as you can imagine
this is where it gets interesting now
Luffy himself grew up in quite terrible
poverty as a kid he saw the terrible
difference between the Nobles and the
people who lived within the literal
trash of those Nobles in the great
terminal in his home on the Goa Kingdom
he was abandoned by his own father and
mother Shanks refused to take him along
as a pirate in fact if it hadn't been
for Shanks sacrificing his arm and his
promise it's very easy to see how Luffy
could have actually ended up much much
different throughout his life he has
dealt with a ton of unfairness and
Injustice before shank's influence he
thought that pirates should fight back
against the slightest grievances like
when the mountain bandage struck Shanks
with a bottle in other words what if
Luffy had never been taught by Shanks
that his tendency for violence was wrong
that he should only fight for things
that are truly important like to defend
the people he cares about what if Luffy
took all of the Injustice that he had
faced in his childhood and decided that
he should just turn the world upside
down down I mean he's already an
absolute force of nature causing
absolute status for the status quo on
any Island he travels to but this time
instead of the world government thinking
he's evil while in reality he's beloved
by the people around the world in this
timeline he would strike fear into the
hearts of just basically anyone kind of
like eustus kid or Blackbeard but way
way worse in fact evil Luffy would
probably look quite a lot like
Blackbeard or even act like him at least
after all let's be real Luffy does drink
enough milk to keep all his teeth for
now now these two members of the worst
generation are pretty much two sides of
the same coin as already is in the main
story just like Blackbeard Luffy would
stop at nothing to achieve his dream of
becoming pirate king even if it means
stomping all over the dreams of other
people the way it is now in the actual
story Luffy lifts people up wherever he
goes but this evil Luffy would bring
them down just like Blackbeard if Luffy
was evil he'd sell out anyone that he
needed to even if it was his own brother
and in this timeline instead of
Blackbeard turning an ace to become a
warlord Luffy would be willing to turn
in his own brother to the Marines if it
means climbing the ladder of the pirate
World faster after all Luffy is no hero
because a hero is someone who shares his
meat but as captain of the evil straw
hats he would be a straight up massive
villain to the one piece world and of
course to be realistic if Luffy actually
was completely EV evil it's very
unlikely that his crew would ever join
him in the first place more likely if
Luffy had a sudden change of heart it
would be up to the straw hats to stop
him from causing some serious harm to
the world instead and that thought
actually leaves us with a really
interesting question is gear five Luffy
so broken that the other straw hats
wouldn't even stand a chance against him
with all their combined forces or with
their combined forces would they
actually be able to stop Luffy's Rage or
who knows is there even someone among
the crew who could stop Luffy in a 1V
one if you're curious to see how such a
battle would shake out you can watch
that video right here where we talk
about exactly what would happen if Luffy
fought all of the straw hats shks so
much for watching please like share
subscribe I know it's annoying but it
really helps the channel otherwise I
hopefully will see you in the next one